buscan devolverle al mundo la normalidad
científicos e ingenieros de distintos
países desarrollan nuevas tecnologías
para combatir el virus o simplemente
para facilitar la vida cotidiana en
medio de la pandemia desde mascarillas
mejoradas pasando por microchips
subcutáneos química de alta tecnología
píldoras y hasta robots de asistencia
en suecia una empresa especializada en
microchips ya promueve el uso de un
diminuto dispositivo que contiene la
información del pase sanitario para ser
escaneado cuando sea necesario aeronave
paterno tienen batería no pueden
transmitir una señal por sí mismos así
que son básicamente pasivos están
siempre dormidos nunca pueden decir tu
ubicación sólo se activan cuando los
tocas en un smartphone los vehículos
aéreos no tripulados para entregar
vacunas contra el cob it facilitan la
logística mientras permiten un control
óptimo de la temperatura de
almacenamiento cuidando así miles de
dosis que se distribuyen durante este
año en estados unidos-ghana y ruanda los
robots se han tomado las calles de
singapur y finlandia para regular el
comportamiento de las personas y
reportar actividades que pongan en
riesgo la salud pública
la logística de los juegos olímpicos de
beijing también estará asistida por
inteligencia artificial con vehículos no
tripulados encargados de entregar
suministros y minimizar la interacción
social utilizamos este carro para
trasladar los materiales dentro y fuera
de la burbuja y el personal puede
los materiales sin salir de su zona en
el sector de la salud en india y canadá
ya empezaron pruebas de un aerosol nasal
a base de plantas y óxido nítrico que
busca reducir los síntomas en primeras
fases del contagio todas las propuestas
que aunque no acaban con el virus hacen
la vida en medio de la pandemia más
fácil y llevadera